neue fundamentale hinweise die gibt es
jetzt wohl im fall maddie zumindest wenn
man den portugiesischen medienberichten
glaubt wir haben den fall für sie
nochmal zusammengefasst
neue erkenntnisse im fall der vermissten
medellín mit cam
in den vergangenen wochen suchte die
portugiesische polizei mit tauchern in
mehreren brunnen nachdem 2007 entführten
britischen met die portugiesische
polizei hat laut medienberichten zufolge
in drei stillgelegten brunnen nach der
mehr als 13 jahre verschwundenen mädchen
gesucht
beamte der kriminalpolizei seien mit
hilfe von tauchern in der gemeinde wie
adobe sbo im einsatz gewesen
die gemeinde liegt knapp 15 km westlich
von praia da luz der ort in dem er die
verschwand ob eine spur des britischen
mädchens in einem der brunnen
aufgetaucht ist ist noch nicht klar
hintergrund am dritten mai 2007
verschwand maddie im urlaub an der
portugiesischen algarve küste aus einer
ferienanlage am dritten mai dieses
jahres die unfassbare wende im
vermisstenfall die deutschen behörden
erklärten dass sie einen verdächtigen
identifiziert haben
christian b als maddie an der algarve
verschwand war christian b 30
er hielt sich zwischen 1995 und 2007 in
einem haus zwischen lagos und praia da
luz auf sowohl in deutschland als auch
in portugal wurde er mehrmals
straffällig hausen ist mir live
zugeschaltet der fall mehr die
beschäftigt uns alle ja irgendwo schon
seit 13 jahren
wie heiß ist die spur die wir jetzt
haben werden diese medien hatten
berichtet dass es fundamentale hinweise
gegeben hatte die eben den anlass für
diese durchsuchung und ermittlungen
gegeben haben
in diesen drei bohnen einer davon den
sieht man hier bei mir im hintergrund
gleichzeitig soll es zuvor
weitere hinweise gegeben haben die
polizei soll mit einem befreundeten
pärchen von christian de gesprochen
haben und anschließend kam es eben
diesen durchsuchungen ist es unklar ob
das miteinander in verbindung steht
britische medien hatten berichtet dass
es einen entscheidenden hinweis von
deutschen ermittlern gegeben hatte die
polizei äußert sich dazu bisher nicht
von daher ist es noch relativ unklar
verstehe aber trotzdem noch mal jan
warum wird jetzt erst in den brunnen
gesucht
wie gesagt aus diesen gründen die ich
eben genannt hatte wurde jetzt danach
gesucht
ich hatte vorher mit einem augenzeugen
sprechen können
der diese polizeiaktion beobachtet hat
gesehen hat es waren ungefähr 15
feuerwehrleute und polizisten hier vor
ort auch ein taucher ich hier ist noch
alles platt getreten hier war vorher
alles noch viel dichter bebildert mit
sträuchern
das heißt man hat hier laut dem
augenzeugen auch mehrere stunden
gearbeitet
was dabei herausgekommen ist ist aber
auch noch nicht ganz klar
ok jan super dann erstmal vielen dank an
dieser stelle